the parents of a drunk driver who
crashed his car and died last December
are suing Tiger Woods and his girlfriend
over their son's death Nick Amos burger
was a bartender at Woods flagship
restaurant in Jupiter Florida his
parents say he died after being served
excessive amounts of alcohol by the
staff Woods girlfriend was the general
manager of the establishment Jim Axelrod
is here with Tiger Woods new legal
battle Jim good morning and I know he's
addressed this now good morning yes in
Florida restaurants and bars are
responsible if they knowingly serve a
customer with an addiction and Emmas
burgers family claims the defendants
knew their son had a drinking problem
now his parents say they're filing this
lawsuit now because the restaurant
destroyed evidence
and even though Woods and his girlfriend
weren't necessarily there the EMAs
burgers say they are responsible he was
a wonderful son Nick him is burgers
mother fought back tears as she talked
about the night her son died five months
ago he had plans he wanted to be a
firefighter in a new lawsuit the family
blames Tiger Woods his girlfriend and
his restaurant for Emma's burgers car
crash December 10th it alleges the
defendant served Emmis burger alcohol to
the point of severe intoxication after
his shift as a bartender ended when he
crashed his car that night Amos burger
had a blood-alcohol content over three
times the legal limit the parents
attorneys say they sued because the bar
allegedly deleted video showing Emma's
burger drinking before the crash they
knew about the crash that night and
shortly thereafter that video evidence
was then destroyed the lawsuit also
states woods and other defendants had
direct knowledge that Emma's burger had
a habitual problem with alcohol yet
continued to serve him at the bar adding
that they not only ignored him as
burgers disease they fueled it woods
responded to the suit yesterday well
we're all very sad that the NIC passed
away it was a terrible terrible night a
terrible ending we feel bad for him and
his entire family Woods life has
recently rebounded after years of legal
trouble
including a DUI arrest two years ago
last month he won the Masters and last
week was awarded the Presidential Medal
of Freedom but Emma's burgers parents
say now would should be punished for
their son's death he was a huge part of
our family and he's left behind four
siblings
he just wasn't finished here yet we
reached out to Tiger Woods attorney for
a response but have not heard back this
all comes says wood is set to tee off in
the second major of the year the PGA
Championship which that's tomorrow
morning thank you Jim